a major media company meantime is
cutting ties with louis c.k over
disturbing allegations of sexual
misconduct the New York Times reports
five women accused the comedian actor of
inappropriate behavior HBO announced it
is pulling louis c.k material from its
on-demand service and said the actor
will no longer appear in an upcoming
special the distributor of CK's new
movie I love you daddy abruptly canceled
its premiere last night CK is the latest
entertainer to become embroiled in a sex
scandal since the accusations against
Harvey Weinstein surfaced and a warning
some of the allegations are graphic how
do women still go out with guys when you
consider the fact that there is no
greater threat to women than men louis
c.k has made a career out of crude dirty
jokes but now five women tell the New
York Times the comedian crossed the line
offstage Chicago comedy duo Dana min
Goodman and Julia wolof told the paper
they met CK at a Comedy Festival in 2002
and thought he was joking when he
offered to undress in front of them he
proceeded to take all of his clothes off
and get completely naked
and started masturbating three other
women accused the actor of inappropriate
conduct including Abby Shatner who says
during a phone conversation she could
hear him masturbating as they spoke CBS
News contributor Jody canter co-authored
the article they were in complete shock
Louie CK is now one of the biggest names
in comedy and so they felt like they
weren't really sure if they could speak
out or say anything this isn't the first
time allegations against CK have
surfaced in 2015 Gawker published a
story which included similar claims but
didn't name the alleged victims Cantor
feels the Harvey Weinstein scandal has
inspired women to end their silence
we're talking about this the cultural
focuses on this people are coming
forward now and they almost don't want
to miss the windows X the network behind
CK's hit series Louie says it is
obviously very troubled by the
allegations but it received no
allegations of misconduct by CK related
to any of it
shows when you read these women's
stories do those jokes sound different
now and I think that's part of the
question about his work that remains a
spokesperson for louis c.k says the
comedian will issue a statement in the
coming days